-It is so great to see you, bud.
Thank you for coming back
and talking to us.
-Yes, sir.
I'm gonna come every time,
pull up right up on you.
You're my guy.
-See?
[ Laughter ]
This is probably --
I think it's the eighth time
that you've been on show,
so I appreciate you being here.
And you've always
been nice to us,
so thanks
for supporting our show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, sir, yes, sir.
-I want to talk about
the two singles first.
What is it, "54321"?
-Yes, sir.
-And "Code" are the two.
-Yes.
-And you're doing
a medley for us tonight.
Congrats.
I know the baby just turned 1.
-Yes, sir, just turned 1.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We did a big one for him.
Big Wave.
-You brought us -- Wave --
and you brought us a video,
which is cool,
of his birthday party.
-Yeah.
-It was, like,
a car-themed party?
-Yeah,
it was a car-themed party.
-1-year-old baby.
-1-year-old baby
with a car-themed party,
you know?
-Yeah, man, 1-year-old,
you gotta --
-Got to do it big on the 1.
-Old enough to get your license,
you gotta get a car.
You know, 1 year old.
I want to show everyone
the video.
Look at this cute thing.
-Okay, Wave, okay!
[ Laughter ]
Yes, sir.
-One, two, three!
-Happy birthday!
-Look at that.
Look at that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Does he know what he's doing?
-Yeah, he was whipping it.
You didn't see him whipping it?
-Does he know what he was doing?
-He was whipping it.
We do it big for our kids.
We love our kids.
We want to have a good time
and bring our family together.
We travel a lot.
We be gone a lot,
so we bring our family together,
make it a big celebration
for the kid.
Even though he 1, you know,
at the end of the day,
we went through life, and we
didn't have opportunities.
I bet if my mama had the chance,
she would have did --
went all out, and did what
she wanted to do for me.
So I'm just lending it
to my kids.
Just letting them see
that they can have another life,
too, you know?
We work hard to do that.
-Exactly, bud.
You do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-You absolutely do.
Your oldest son, Jordan?
-Yes.
-He showed you something.
It was at the party
or around the time?
He was showing that he's on a --
-Yeah, we was in the house,
and I went downstairs,
and he was on the computer,
and I heard, like,
a beat being made.
So I look, and I look,
and he making a beat.
And I'm just listening,
so I record him.
And I posted it.
Everybody's like,
"Oh, it's hard, it's hard."
So I'm like --
I asked him, like, "How long
you been working on beats?"
'Cause he always play sports --
football, basketball.
He always been good at that.
He played in sports.
-You didn't think he was gonna
get into music.
-I didn't --
I had no clue he had a lap --
so he like -- I been having
FruityLoops on my laptop.
Learned how to play.
So he played it for me,
so I'm just trying to let him
get nice and seasoned,
and then I'm -- I'm probably
gonna do something with him
for the album.
-No way.
-I feel like that'd be crazy,
yeah.
-I want to talk about the show
"The Hype."
-Yes, sir.
-Because this is --
It's almost like
a "Project Runway" type of show
but it's about streetwear.
-Yes.
-And you're one of the judges.
It's a great idea.
You're also one of
the producers.
-Yes, sir.
-What made you decide
to do a show about streetwear?
-Because streetwear, like,
it leads the culture in fashion.
Like, even with
the big designer brands,
and a lot of those names
get their designs stolen.
And they don't have the platform
to show that they created this.
And it's like they're getting
buried while the bigger brands
is like taking the source
and running with it.
So I just wanted
to put a show together
where we put the light on them
and let them shine,
because the art
is coming from them,
and it's getting took
from other brands.
And they're getting
taken advantage of.
They don't have the platform.
So with "The Hype,"
you get the -- if you win,
you win $150,000,
and then,
throughout the challenges,
you get to be on StockX
and, like, different platforms
with streetwear.
It's the biggest for streetwear.
-StockX, yeah, it's a big deal.
But is it tough to be a judge
with these designers?
'Cause you're like --
You can't really say "No,"
or, "That's not good."
-I mean --
Well, with my show,
I kept it 100 on that.
So, like, I wasn't
saying yes to everything.
If I didn't like it,
I didn't like it.
Like, one time, it was a
challenge, and I didn't like it,
so we had to create a whole
new challenge and start over.
Even on the other side
of production,
like writing it together,
because I can't stamp nothing
that I'm not gonna represent.
I'm not gonna be fake.
And then, in the world of
fashion, it's rough, it's hard.
It's like,
it's a lot of judgment.
You got to come
with something unique
that somebody else
ain't already did.
And it's not nice,
so I'm just training them
to get to the next level.
-That's good.
Pay it forward.
I want to show everyone a clip
of season two of "The Hype."
Take a look at this.
-I'm representing
for masculine girls.
Millions of us, you know?
Now I'm modelling myself.
I don't do that,
so we can all do it.
But I want to show you
something, though.
-Yeah.
Put me on.
-So I took the time and put some
intention in my garment.
It says "Queens get the money.
Damn X, awake New York."
-Wow!
Okay. All right.
Queens get the money!
Dollar dollar bill, y'all!
You feel me?
I'm smelling that.
-Season two of "The Hype"
premiers September 22nd
on HBO Max.
Offset will be performing for us
later tonight.